-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with
MSNBC's Chris Hayes.
Look, a lot of attention
was paid to it today,
but do you think, due to all
the noise around this election
and the long tail of results
that we have --
it's fully sunk in
the historic accomplishment of
Kamala Harris as Vice President?
-I was glad that
it was hammered home today
I do think
it hasn't quite sunk in.
I mean, at some level I thin
there is something
kind of good about that, insofar
as because that primary cast -
that that field was so diverse
there was a certain kind o
normalizing effect of that
-Right.
-Like, you know, people --
gay and straight,
black and white,
children, immigrant or not
you know, women and men.
Like, that is how it should be
And I do think that followin
that for a year and a half
sort of created sort of
expectations, but of course,
it's an enormously consequential
moment in American history
and obviously, part of
the subtext of a lot of
the battles that we're havin
over what the sort of
future defining feature
of the country is.
-When you were here right afte
the election in 2016,
you talked about politics always
has sort of
an opposite reaction
and this belief that
if Donald Trump was the opposite
of Barack Obama,
there would be an opposite
to what Donald Trump brought
In the end, is Joe Biden -
is the Biden administratio
the opposite you thought i
would be?
-That's really interesting
I think in some ways he is
insofar as, you know,
all these jokes about
sort of boring or traditional.
-Yes.
-That here is this person
who was wildly untraditional
and also obsessive about
attention in this way that
you know, broke down all these
kind of expectations and norms
Joe Biden is
the opposite of that.
I think that it's deeper
than personality though, right
It's about the way
the coalitions react,
and I think that like, you know,
when I was on the show
four years ago
right after the election
and I talked about this sort o
opposite reaction, it's like the
day after Trump's inauguration
you had the Million Women March,
the Women's March,
and you had millions of people
in the streets
around the country,
and that didn't really sto
for four years, right?
Like, that activated
this opposite reaction,
and today is kind of the
fruition of all of that work
all of that reaction of people
saying like, "No, that's not -
that's not what I believe
my country
should be and look like."
And that doesn't stop now.
Like, that kind of
thermostatic reaction of
American popular opinion and the
way in which opposition form--
like, the thing
we got to figure out,
which I thought Biden spok
about well today, is, like
how to make the parry and thrust
of politics happen in a bo
that's more democratic
and more normal
and less threatening
about the end of democracy
which is what we've just kin
of, like, narrowly avoided
-Right, which is -- you know
again, only two weeks ago.
And again, President Biden
addressed it today.
Again, tone is not going t
be what solves it,
although I think tone here i
helpful, because you want to
bring down the temperature
a little bit.
-It matters a lot. I agree
-How do you --
You know, how does a Biden
administration move forwar
and try to, you know --
you know, are these people tha
can be brought to the table?
-You know, I don't -- That i
the great unsolved questio
of contemporary
American politics.
I mean, one of the lessons
Barack Obama learned is that
you cannot produce unity
or cooperation unilaterally.
Like, you can do
all the things
and you can extend your hand
but if Mitch McConnell is like
"Sorry, dude,"
you can't make him do anything
-Right.
-So that lesson endures.
One thing that I think
is different here,
and I think this is so
crucial -- the impeachment
And here's why.
In 2009, you know, there was
the "look forward, not back.
There was a desire to deal wit
the crisis at hand.
There was a sense that
spending political capital
on accountability for the
previous administration
would be wasted when it could be
put to use
on, you know,
getting the votes now.
The impeachment
has closed the door
on letting everyone just say
"Well, whew, that was weird,
huh?"
Like, no, we have to go back
and litigate that thing.
The thing that happened
two weeks ago
when the mob incited by
the president, like,
apparently beat a cop to death
we're not just --
that's not in the past.
That has to be dealt with in a
formal constitutional procedure,
in which before the nation
we will litigate what happened
and the president's culpability,
and I think that is so important
because it demands that we don't
just turn the page on it,
because we can't turn
the page on it, because there is
going to be a trial.
And thank God
there is going to be.
-Now, of course, we did have -
we're in this rare situation
where we can see how
an impeachment affected
Donald Trump and his supporters,
right?
The first one arguably
had no effect.
-Yeah.
-I bet if you did exit polling
on whether or not, you know,
people in November
were choosing based on --
-Oh, I think it had --
-This one does feel different.
I mean, you know, it might b
just wishful thinking on my part
that people would perceive
this differently.
-Yeah, I think --
Well, he's less powerful.
He's not the sitting President
of the United States.
He's not facing re-electio
immediately, and, you know
I think there's a real choice to
be made for the Republican Party
and the leadership,
particularly McConnell,
who I think basically
holds his fate in his hands.
McConnell wants the 17 votes
-You think he can get them
-Yes. Absolutely.
If he wants them,
he can get them.
I just think that it does
come down to McConnell,
and I do think there are
probably 17 votes,
if McConnell wants it
to be the case,
and what that would mean,
I think, is afterwards,
were he to be removed,
there would be a majority vote
about barring him
from future office,
which I think is a no-brainer.
Obviously this person
can't be trusted
with the public trust
after what he's done.
That's not a close call.
And, you know, if you're
the Republican Party, it's like,
you have a very rare opportunity
that is almost never
afforded anyone,
to, in an official
and binding way,
repudiate this poisonous
presence in your midst.
You know, you don't really
ever get to do that.
You can shun people,
you can say,
"I won't take his endorsement,
yadda, yadda.
This is like a binding
constitutional procedure to say,
"The man has forfeited
the public trust."
-The interesting calculus of
and I think we're dealing with
a lot of people who are
pretty calculating,
is, you know, if you are
a Hawley or a Cruz,
I would think a specter
that would hang over
any future ambitions you hav
for the office of the presidency
would be that Donald Trump
would run again.
-Yeah.
-So, even though I think
they are playing to a base
that also supports him
and would be furious
if they voted to impeach him
like, I mean,
what are their odds in 202
as a actual presidential
candidate if Donald Trump
decides to run for office again?
-I agree completely,
and I think that's
partly the calculation here.
The other part of it I think
too, is if you're Hawley or Cruz
or any of those people,
if the party goes in
the Trumpian direction,
which it may, you're not
going to be the nominees.
-Right.
-Like, if that's the way
they go,
they're not gonna be like,
"Oh, the Princeton-Harvard clerk
who's got a beard
and is, like, from Texas."
"Oh, the banker's son
who went to private school
and went to Yale and wrote
the book on Teddy Roosevelt?
Like, who now is Mr. Populous?
No, I don't think
it's happening.
I mean, it's gonna be
like Don Jr.
[ Laughs ]
Like, who are we kidding?
-Or it's somebody who we haven't
conceived of yet.
-Exactly.
-Like, if Trump continues to
you know, exponentially play
out, it will get Trumpier
in a way than we cannot
really conceive of.
-Yes, we don't know the person
who has a YouTube channel
right now that's gonna be
the next Republican nominee.
-Right, who's, like,
named after a dessert.
It's like, no, it's gonna be
Creme Brulee.
He's like this alt-right guy
[ Laughter ]
Hey, you have a fan,
somebody that I'm a fan of -
Leslie Jones.
-Yes.
-I think one of the great
developments of this past year
is that she --
"Game of Thrones" ended and sh
started watching you on MSNBC.
Of all the things
we could've predicted.
But I do -- This is one of
my new favorite things
when I have a guest on
is showing them a clip of --
this is Leslie Jones
watching Chris.
-He got this condescending, "get
your [bleep] together" look.
Look at this look
he got on his face.
"I am sick of saying this
to you, mother[bleep].
And y'all know that this i
wrong what's happening.
Why ain't you doing nothing?
You know what?
[Bleep] it.
I'm going to Chipotle."
[ Laughter ]
-I forget every time
we show a Leslie clip,
our energy bill goes up
from all the beeping.
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I know you're gonna
be on air tonight
for a couple of long chunk
tonight.
-For a couple long chunks, yeah.
-We're very lucky to have yo
on the air.
-Oh, it's so great to be here.